Oh my god.
Bro, oh my fucking god.
I did not realize!
Just how- oh my- This game, I'll just say like this fucking game.
Holy shit, this fucking game.
Oh my god, the amount of hoops I have to jump to get this- guys, I'm so sorry that we're an hour late.
I'm so sorry.
It was- it was hell.
It truly was hell trying to get this game to work.
Oh, that's all I'll say.
Was it worth it?
I don't know!
I mean, it's so cute though.
Okay, I need to tell you guys the story.
I'm so sorry.
We're an hour late.
I went through a whole fucking adventure trying to get this to work, but I hope the volume's okay right now.
I hope the volume's okay.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
A certified Apple moment.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Normal size phantom.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Well, dokey, was it worth it?
All right, so god, this song is so fucking like...
All right, let me tell you guys like the...
How this whole shit went through.
So, um...
Oh, you can bring down the music a little.
Okay, I'm gonna like... I'm like really worried.
Because I didn't manage to create a new account.
So I'm gonna be very careful right now.
I'm gonna... Let me... Let me turn this off real quick.
So... Okay, so I'm gonna turn down the music, right?
Okay, bring down the music a little bit.
Okay.
I'm gonna bring down the music a little bit.
I'm... I'm like paranoid as hell right now.
So, anyway...
Let me tell you the adventure I had to have... My own little adventure that I had to have.
Um, before... Before we had... We were able to get all of this to work.
So, my little adventure is that basically what happened was that, um, I woke up and I was like...
Uh...
What happened was that, um, I realized... I was like, wait a minute.
Because I don't know.
This must be an old iPad.
Because I was like... I was like, I don't need to.
I was like, oh man, I don't... I don't need to have a...
Um, I don't need to have a new iPad.
You know, I have so much streaming experience.
I can just use... Because I don't have an iPad.
I use my dad's iPad.
I was like...
I don't need a new iPad.
I'll just borrow my parents iPad.
Because iPads are so fucking expensive.
What I didn't realize is that, um, this is...
Is this like a particularly old iPad?
You know it's a particularly old iPad because the adapter...
The iPad adapter is still like...
The adapter is still USB-C.
It's not a lightning adapter.
You know, it was before when Apple...
You know, it was before when Apple decided to...
You know, make everything using the lightning adapter.
Like...
Like made everything...
So, you know it's old when the iPad is still using USB-C before the Apple was like...
Nuh-uh.
We're gonna make everything lightning.
So...
So, I didn't realize I didn't have the adapter for the...
For to use for the game capture.
Because I was like, oh yeah, I can just...
I...
I can just, you know, I'll just use this...
This game capture adapter that I have for my iPhone.
That I use to stream with my iPhone.
And then I was like, wait a minute.
Why doesn't it fit?
Oh, I meant the 30 pin.
Sorry.
The 30 pin.
I don't remember.
It's one of them.
Okay.
I don't remember.
Okay, so...
Um...
Anyway.
Uh...
I just know that like the one I have is not...
Does not work.
Because like it doesn't fit into the one.
Because it...
I was like, okay, so I need to...
I need to buy...
I need to go to...
I need to go to an electronic store and buy an adapter.
Because I was like, oh, I'll just use my Android adapter.
You know?
Yeah.
The one when I had the Android pad.
I don't know.
What do they call the Android iPad?
Do they just call it the Android tablet?
Sorry.
Anyway.
I just need the Android tablet to...
Um...
Because I have the adapter to stream my Android tablet.
Because this game is an Apple exclusive.
By the way, I hope the sound's okay.
I turned down the sound on my end.
Oh, there was no sound.
There's no music at all.
You just hear the fucking ambience.
Never mind.
Uh...
Anyway.
So...
Um...
I was like, all right.
I have an adapter for Android tablets.
And like my cable for the iPad fits an Android tablet.
So I'll use the Android tablet adapter to plug into my game capture.
That would work, right?
So...
It didn't.
Um...
It would kept crashing.
The game capture kept crashing.
Because who would have thought?
Uh...
It didn't work.
So...
So I was like, okay.
We gotta go to the electronic store.
And like...
We gotta go to the electronic store and buy the adapter.
The app.
Apple.
You know, like...
Cause you know.
The Apple approved adapter that can connect to the game capture.
So I bought that.
And then I came back.
And I was like, all right.
Good.
We should be able to stream now.
And then I was like, wait a minute.
I can't buy any games because this account is, you know, my dad's account.
And I need a password.
So I was like, okay.
I'm gonna log out and create a new account.
And then it wouldn't let me.
It wouldn't let me put in a phone number.
It wouldn't let me put in a phone number to create a new account.
It wouldn't let me do like two factors.
It wouldn't let me like sync a payment to it.
So I was like, okay.
I'm just gonna log into my dad's account.
I was like, dad, what's the password?
And he was like, I don't know.
It's like, I don't know.
I don't know what the fucking password is.
I don't know.
I was like, okay.
It's a Yahoo account, dad.
Do you remember?
He's like, I don't fucking know who uses Yahoo anymore.
And I was like, oh no, my iPad went to sleep.
Oh no.
Okay.
It's gonna be a black screen until my iPad's not sleeping.
Anyway.
I was like, okay.
Then why don't you like, can you like log in?
He's like, no.
And I can't log out.
Cause I need the password to log out.
So, so, so, and then I was like, okay, what if I log out on the iTunes store on the iTunes app store?
And, and then, and then, um, I'll log into my accounts or like to like your other account.
He's like, oh yeah, I have another account you can log into.
And then, so I logged into the other dad account that he has, that's a Gmail account and not a Yahoo account.
Cause he actually has access to it.
And then, and then we realized.
That his Gmail account is, um, his, his Gmail account is not registered in NA.
So the store for those who don't know Hello Kitty Island Adventure is a, is an Apple exclusive.
And it's also only in NA or like, I don't definitely not in Asia.
It's, it's definitely not in Asia.
So I was like, oh fuck.
Okay.
Now I need to figure out.
Can I change the store country, the country of the store.
So I changed the country of the store and then I changed it.
But then they're like, well, we need a payment card for Canada.
So I was like, all right, I'll just put my cards on.
And they're like, we can't verify this payment.
I was like, okay, I'll just use PayPal.
And they're like, we can't verify this either.
And I was like, okay.
I'm fucking.
So, so yeah, we, it was region locked to a specific.
So I was like, okay.
And then my dad, they was like, oh my God, we have your, we have access to the Yahoo account.
Cause like they were like, look, my dad and mom was looking through like various cause like, okay.
Um, um, they've been, they've been using Apple phones for a long time since Apple iPhones were since iPhones were like first introduced when the iPhone was made of metal.
Was it metal?
It was like, I remember like the very first iPhone was like metal and it was like super heavy and all of that.
So like they were just looking through like metal.
And then they were like, oh, I'm going to go through the collections of iPhones.
And one of them still had the Yahoo account registered to the iPhone.
To the iPhone.
They're like, we got it.
We got access to the iPhone.
We got access to the Yahoo mail.
Cause they were looking through like the collection of phones and like one of the phones, one of the phones slash iPads had access.
Like had access.
Like had literal access to the, to the Yahoo account.
So we were able to change the password and they're like, you change it since you're going to use it.
You use the password for it.
And then, so then I had to change the password and then now, and then I finally, I bought Hello Kitty Island Adventure.
Oh my God.
It was truly a fucking adventure to actually get started playing Hello Kitty Island Adventure.
And oh my God.
It was so painful.
I was like, I couldn't believe we had to go through so much just to play this fucking game.
Did you write?
I wrote the password.
The struggles we go through for Hello Kitty.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It really was a fucking journey to get here just to play this fucking game.
Anyway, for those who are like, what is Hello Kitty Island Adventure?
I'm like, I don't know.
It's essentially like, it's essentially like a Animal Crossing, but instead of like Animal Crossing characters, it's just all Samuel characters.
And it's, but it's only on the apples.
Like Apple devices apparently can play on the mac and everything, but like...
Yeah.
I think the only people who use Mac, I'm so sorry to all the Mac users.
But I feel like the only people who use like
I'm not sure if you're seeing this on the video.
So, like, I'm not sure if you're seeing this on the video.
I guess, like, normies, I guess.
But I don't know.
Same here.
I don't know who buys a Mac anymore.
But I know a lot of, like, video audio editors still use the Mac for, like, stuff there, I guess.
Yes, like...
But yes, it's sadly only an Apple exclusive and it really was...
so painful to get here.
Alright, here we go.
I'm like... alright.
Yay!
Wanna go fishing?
Batsumaru can teach you to make a fishing rod!
Yay!
We're loading!
Okay, I'm gonna get rid of this like thumb thing over here.
Alright, it's gonna bother you.
It might bother you guys a little bit, but I'm just gonna...
Oh, you're awake!
Hi there!
I'm Hello Kitty!
Please don't dox my family.
Hello Kitty, please let me fill in my own name.
That's all I ask, Ms. Kitty.
That's all I ask of you.
Okay, alright, alright.
Are you ready for a vacation at Big Adventures Park?
Yes.
Uh, yes.
We should be arriving soon, so you wanna freshen up, but now is the time!
Oh my god, Hello Kitty, big fan!
You know, guys, I'm gonna say, I think... I think she's overrated.
I think it was super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doctor, thank you, super chat.
Your life is in her hands now.
Oh my god, your entire life is in Hello Kitty's hands.
Alright, I'm gonna... I don't know.
I don't know what she's gonna say!
Okay, oh thank god.
Oh my god, it's so cute!
Oh my god, I'm basically you, dragon!
I don't think I have to change anything!
I don't...
Oh my god!
I actually just don't have to change anything!
Okay, wait, let's see.
Maybe the eyes, maybe.
Oh wait, wait, where?
Oh my god, wait!
Wait, this is the... this is the dragon hairstyle!
Wait, this is literally the dragon hairstyle!
Right?
Yeah!
It's like this.
And then...
Okay, wait, I actually like that.
Wait, this or...
Wait, actually, either this...
Oh no, this.
Actually, or this.
Wait, they're all so good!
Instead of doxing me, I dox you guys.
Okay, wait, they're all so fucking good!
Okay, I don't know.
Oh my gosh, I can't... they're all so cute.
Need the stupid eyes?
Which one's the stupid eyes?
They're all pretty dumb.
They're all pretty dumb though.
Which one's the stupid ones?
Alright.
Maybe...
Either this or... this.
I don't know.
I don't... okay.
Left, right.
One, two.
Which one guys?
One or two guys?
One, two.
One...
What?
This?
This one?
Okay, one, two, three.
One, two, three.
Which one?
Chat.
One, two, three.
Two?
Okay, I see more twos.
Alright.
Beaks.
Oh, that's like a duck beak.
Okay, this one is... that's an eagle.
I feel like this or this.
Did I break it?
Oh, I was gonna say.
I think maybe... this one looks more like a dragoon.
This one and then... what is this?
Oh, it's like the face markings.
Okay, I think this one definitely.
I think we got it.
Can we change clothes?
Oh, we can.
Okay.
Sorry, I just thought...
Okay, let's see.
No hats because we can't afford hats right now.
Alright.
I think... I think...
Wait, should we give you a... this shirt or a green shirt?
Guys.
Damn.
Rob.
Black shirt?
You guys want a black shirt?
We meant three?
Okay, five.
Oh, wait.
No shirt.
This one?
You want this?
No, three.
Wait, I don't want you guys to wear a shirt.
Wait, can I not get...
Nice.
Okay, this is good.
Alright.
Okay, we're good.
I think this is perfect.
I think...
Honestly, I think this is perfect.
Yes.
The...
The pure dragoon.
Dragoon uncut right there.
The no filter dragoon right here.
Doki, this is... This is...
What is there?
What am I exposing?
You have nothing.
There's literally nothing.
Dragoons.
There's nothing.
Finally, dragoon cheek talk.
Surreal.
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
My eyes are up there, ladies.
Alright, accept.
Yay!
You look great!
Oh my gosh, thank you, Miss Kitty.
If you want to change your appearance later, you can do so at any time at a mirror.
Okay, nice.
We don't...
No, you guys are perfect right there.
I think you're perfect.
Just as the way you look like.
What?
You guys never wore any pants?
Even before.
You might have worn a shirt, but never any pants.
What are you exposing right now?
Nothing.
We still have some time.
You can meet others on our flight if you like to.
Come talk to me.
I feel like you're done chatting.
Okay.
Oh my God, look!
Press to move.
Okay.
Move.
Talk to some of the passengers.
Okay.
What?
Oh, I'm right here.
But like...
Okay, here.
Oh my God!
Look, I'm moving!
I'm naked!
You're naked!
Talk to me.
Tuxedo Sam.
Greetings and salutations.
Tuxedo Sam, at your service.
An honor.
Nice to meet you.
Making new friends is always delightful and quite inspiring.
You see, I'm both a designer and collector...
Oh, they're gonna let me... give me clothes later.
We don't need clothes though.
CJ, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We love you.
Don't...
Okay, cool and cute.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Please don't hesitate to ask.
Okay, this is the guy we're never gonna talk to.
Cause like, we're never gonna need clothes.
Nothing makes me happier than helping my friends look their best.
If you'll excuse me, I feel inspiration about to strike.
Alright.
I wanna talk to Kuromi.
Are you still talking to new friends or do you wanna meet them?
No, I'm still chatting.
Wait, I wanna talk to Kuromi!
But I can jump too?
Oh my god.
Kuromi!
Let me bother you!
Hey, how are you?
I can't wait to see the island.
Oh, this is like the Animal Crossing in the beginning where you're talking to people before you arrive in the town.
The name's Kuromi.
Don't believe anything those two jokers, Batsmata and Kuromi say about me.
Yeah, they're all wrong.
You're always right, miss.
My queen.
I see you noticed my book.
I've been collecting vintage tickets, posters, and pretty much anything I could find.
Sometimes I didn't even think it was real.
Like maybe it was an elaborate hoax.
So I decided to film an episode of my show.
Kuromi explains it all.
Oh my god, she's famous.
Of course she is.
She's a queen.
But my Melisandre could just enjoy myself.
Don't listen to that bitch.
I'm just hoping Wookiee Swamps lives up to his reputation.
Do what you wanna do, my queen.
Alright.
CJ, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What will hella kid you think?
She loves it.
What do you mean?
Oh my god.
Get out of the way.
I'm talking.
No, get out of the way.
I only wanna talk to one person.
Get out of the way.
I wanna talk to Papa Bird.
I don't care about you.
I don't care about you poochy whatever.
Oh my god.
That's...
Oh my gosh.
I can't remember how to say your name.
Ritsuko.
I was like thinking about the show's name.
I haven't watched the last two seasons of Ritsuko yet.
Agatsuko.
Miss Flight Se...
Like you...
Okay, so spoiler alert.
There was a scene where like she gets dumped and then she settles for this other guy.
And then I was so mad that I never watched...
I never...
I didn't watch the season after.
I was so...
I was so mad.
I was like why did you settle for him?
He's a fucking loser.
I'm sorry for all those...
All those people that actually like this particular character.
I...
I was...
I wish he...
That guy went with this other girl and not her because she...
Ritsuko deserves so much more.
I'm just gonna say.
She...
She deserves so much more.
She does not deserve...
He does not deserve her.
And then I never watched the last two seasons.
I watched the season after that because I was so sad that like she dumped that other guy.
This flight search seems like it's taking forever.
I grabbed it because my original flight got cancelled.
I think we're almost there.
Please my eyes are up here, Ms. Ritsuko.
It's nice to meet you.
I'm Ritsuko.
I took some time off from work because I have a really stressful job.
Oh yeah.
She said OL by the way.
I was hoping a break from the office would be good for me.
I think...
I'm thinking about my boss and the work that's probably piling up.
I'm getting even more freaked out.
No!
I don't know anyone in the plane but they seem to all know each other.
Don't worry Ritsuko.
You can know me.
But my eyes are up here by the way.
They do seem unusually friendly though.
You already gave me gifts.
Oh my god.
Where's my gifts?
It was nice meeting you.
It was nice meeting you too Ritsuko.
Okay.
I'm done.
If I can't talk to Pom Pom Purin then I don't care anymore.
All right.
I'm ready.
Where's Tsunomaru?
This is such an exciting opportunity for my...
Okay.
I don't care about her either.
It's not everyday you get invited to open this door on the tropical island resort.
And who talked to you my Melody?
No one asked for you Melody?
And theme park.
We're here to support you my Melanie.
Oh, I can't say no.
Oh, thank you!
You're both so kind!
I'm ready to land.
Take me down.
I want my new village.
Do I keep being rude?
I didn't ask her to talk to me!
She butted into the conversation!
Mv, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you!
I think Kuromi actually has episodes of her show on the Hylokitty and Friends YouTube.
Oh my god.
I love how each Sanrio character actually has their own YouTube channel.
In Japanese.
And they actually upload cover music videos too, which is funny.
I'll go get you a slice.
Just wait for me at your seat, okay?
Look, I want to make new friends.
But not Melody.
Not Melody.
Not some of the people here.
Okay.
I get to pick and choose which...
...Sanrio character I want to be friends with.
Is there a fucking oven in the plane?
That should not do well with the air pressure.
So delicious.
As long as I input the settings right, of course.
Okay, let's see.
Why is there an oven on the plane?
Is that safe?
Beep.
Boop.
Error.
Please press bake to send an error report.
Oh no!
What did Kitty do?
What did you do, Kitty?
Who put an oven on the plane?
Oh no.
Free food.
My second rule.
I can't turn it off.
More geeks keep flying out.
Everybody hold on your lunches.
It's about to...
Oh my god.
The cake caused turbulence.
How?
It's too much cake.
There's the island.
We're so close.
Oh no.
There's smoke coming out of the plane.
Are we just gonna fucking...
Oh no.
That's Mario.
Enough is enough.
I've had it with these cake...
Oh.
Oh my god.
I'm so sorry.
It's the cakes on the plane.
Wait.
It's cakes on the plane.
What?
Everyone take some balloons.
We're gonna have to jump.
Okay.
Don't worry.
Single file, everybody.
Single file as we jump off the plane.
Wait.
But is the plane gonna...
Is it gonna crash?
What year is it?
These motherfucking cakes on this motherfucking plane.
Don't worry.
These balloons will keep you safe.
I promise.
Hang on tight.
Okay.
I hope so.
Wow.
I see balloons.
Jump.
Okay.
Yay.
Oh shit.
I didn't know about this.
I can move.
The fuck?
How do I...
Jump and float to the...
Oh.
Guys.
Whoa.
Maybe I'll hit one ring.
I did it.
Guys.
I got a ring.
I got one.
That's all that matters.
Guys.
I got one.
Okay.
Do you happen to know this-this word?
How can we find it?
No.
I didn't care.
Chococat found one of the resort's map and scanned it.
Here, I'll send it to you.
Okay.
Just open the map on your phone and look for my Melody.
You need help finding.
Do I have to find her?
Find three strawberry- The guy in light will show you where to go just follow it.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I have my own iPhone within my iPad.
When you find her, would you give her the strawberry?
Yay!
Gosh, this looks so weird that you're naked.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, Airpoint.
No one should be lost on an island without a healthy snack.
Wait, where's my snack though?
You gotta find my Melody.
Oh wait, there's something over here.
What is this?
I got a game ticket.
Oh my gosh, there's gonna be video games.
I got mystic stone.
There's so much stuff here.
Strawberry crate.
I mean, she has to be here.
This is literally her house.
Did she just... no?
Oh my god!
Okay, we're gonna be nice to Melody.
She owns the store.
Guys, we have to be nice to her now.
Because she has a store, guys.
Okay guys, we need to have like...
She's like... oh, she's like the Tom Nooks in Animal Crossing.
What is this?
The strawberry crate.
Happy landings?
Oh, they're like active quests.
Okay.
Where's the... I need to find...
Track progress.
Show guide, please.
I'm baby.
Tell me where to go.
Okay, it is right... Okay, she's over there.
Okay, we can do that.
Oh my god, they have a discord too and everything.
Holy shit.
Alright.
Oh my god, thank god for the guiding light.
Thank god.
Is that her?
She's over here.
Ma'am, where's the namoro?
Where's the real star?
Would you like a strawberry?
Miss Melody?
A gift?
That's so thoughtful.
I know all me.
I found it just for you.
Try gifting a strawberry to me.
You know like...
Oh my god, she's so demanding.
Better than yellow paint.
I know, right?
Oh my god.
I already... You need it to be wrapped.
This is why I don't like Melody.
She's so...
She's so high maintenance.
Kuromi wouldn't care.
She'd just be happy that I fucking got her a strawberry.
I didn't need to wrap it for her.
So demanding.
I wonder if I like suck up to her and she'll like give me discounts for her store.
Be mean again?
She literally told me to wrap her gift for her.
She knew I was gonna give her a strawberry.
Giving gifts is a great way to make friends.
I try to pick gifts that everyone likes.
For example, how a kitty likes fruity things.
Like an apple pie.
That's Mario likes jokes and gags.
So I'll give him a...
Okay, this is a good one.
These are another people I wanna get close to.
Each time you give someone someone like, your friendship with them will continue to grow.
They'll also give you gifts in return which can be very useful.
Try learning what everyone likes and becoming good friends.
Oh, and you can only give three gifts a day to each friend.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, I understand now.
By the way, have you seen anyone else since you arrived?
In the plaza.
That's where everybody is.
Great!
Lead the way!
Oh my god.
Now this isn't...
Oh, I got a flower!
New friend!
You're now friends with my Melody.
Okay, follow me miss.
Don't worry, I have the guiding light so I won't get lost ever again.
Hello, hello kitty.
I got Melody here.
Wait, I don't see Kuromi.
Where is she?
Where's Kuromi?
By my calculations, she's here.
Half our party seems to be absent.
No!
I just realized all the ones I hate are on this side!
I'm missing...
Yeah, wasn't there Retsuko?
Yeah, what about Retsuko?
They forgot about Retsuko?
They're like...
Isn't there one more per...
That is so fucked up.
Retsuko is so much more famous than you, pochi.
Hello?
Can I help?
Oh, oh dear.
She didn't make it.
Who is that?
A ghost?
I believe it was a hologram.
Sophisticated technology but deteriorated.
She's so smart.
The island has only become more mysterious since we arrived.
I'm going to set up camp.
We need a base of operation to discover what's afoot and find everyone.
Oh my god, he's like Sherlock Holmes.
That's a good idea.
We should split up, gang.
Look for clues.
When this becomes Scooby Doo.
Split up?
You should never split the party.
Batsumaru, you watch too many scary movies.
I'm serious!
There's no one here!
There's not even staff!
Don't stop slandering my boy, pochi.
Bro!
He started it!
He didn't think Retsuko was important enough.
But Retsuko is more famous than him because she has a TV show.
Where's his TV show?
And don't say he was in the Hello Kitty show because it literally says Hello Kitty.
He was a guest star.
I don't know.
I was supposed to be staffed.
And look!
There's my new store.
They specifically said I needed furniture and decorations in my shop.
Maybe we can fix up the cabins for our own visitors.
And that looks like a place where I can make food for all of us.
All of us?
Even me?
Fine.
I'll go check by the beach.
Maybe there will be a snack bar or something.
He's part of the friends.
Hello Kitty and friends.
He's in the friend section, doki.
Why don't you see if my Melody needs any help?
It must suck to be Melody because like her sister...
Is Kuromi...
No, Kuromi is not sister.
Kuromi is just a really good friend.
Right?
Or was it cousin?
I don't know.
The lore keeps changing.
I don't remember if Kuromi is supposed to be like cousin, sister or a friend.
But like Melody is just jealous because Kuromi ended up being more popular than her.
Alright.
Help Melody at the gift shop.
Where do you want help from?
Welcome to the grand opening of Small Gift Bag Smiles.
That's a terrible name Melody.
I was like what?
Did I read this correct?
Wait.
That's a terrible name Melody.
Did I read that story name correct?
Small Gift Big Smile Tropical Edition.
It was sweet of you to come and find me earlier.
I'm sure you'll find the rest of our friends too.
And when you do, I just have the thing.
I want to see.
What do you have Melody?
You see, I brought welcome gifts for all our friends.
When you find them, you make sure to brighten your day with these gifts.
Oh, I'm an excellent gift giver.
I am.
Thank you so much.
This will be a great way for you to make friends with everyone here.
Pay to win.
Okay, the moment Cinnamoroll gets here, I'm going to fucking spend so much money.
So that Cinnamoroll will be my friend.
You know Cinnamoroll is a guy?
Just so you guys know.
And he has a girlfriend too.
He had a girlfriend.
Soon.
Each time you give someone a gift.
Give someone you like.
Your friendship with them will grow.
They'll also give you gifts in return.
Which can be very useful.
Try learning what everyone likes and becoming good friends.
Oh, and you can only give three gifts a day to each friend.
Are you ready to find your friends and give some gifts?
Oh, I'm ready.
I'm ready.
Lovely.
Here are the gifts I need delivered.
Please be people I like.
Hello, kitties.
Welcome...
Okay.
That it?
Oh, and don't forget to tell everyone that small gift, big smile, tropical edition is open for your furniture and rooms.
Will do.
I like how they have the...
They have the frog cupboard.
Which is similar.
Okay.
Hello kitty, choco cat.
That's...
Oh, it's basically everybody.
This is like the frog chair in Animal Crossing.
But now...
But now it's like a fucking...
Shelf.
All right, let's go.
We gotta find them.
I like the froggy mirror.
I mean, it's pretty cute.
Okay.
Hello kitty is like right here.
She's like right here.
Jump, jump, jump.
Oh, if you hold it...
Wait, what shop is this?
Is this a coffee shop?
Is hello kitty the...
The pigeon in this game?
Oh my God.
Can I sit down?
Something seems to be missing.
Oh, the...
The umbrella.
Don't worry, kitty.
I'll do your job for you.
Wait, how do I put it down?
Oh, I see.
How do I...
Something's missing, but how do I put it down?
Collection?
No.
Can I look at my bag?
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, it doesn't matter.
All right, never mind.
I can just think about it.
I think Hiromi and Batsumaru are...
Shut your mouth.
Gee.
You're so...
She need no mat.
No, there's no way.
She deserves so much better.
There's no way.
I refuse to let her date Batsumaru.
There's no fucking way.
Oh, good.
I could see Sanrio game.
I was worried about to see something like that Sonic movie maker game.
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
There's no way.
Batsumaru?
No way.
There's no way.
There's...
I refuse to believe that they are a couple.
He is so beneath her.
Oh, I got tofu.
Nice.
New friend.
Let's see.
Here.
Now, new friends with Hello Kitty.
Yay.
Wait.
What does Hello Kitty want?
Isn't this the cutest cafe?
It's wonderful.
She...
Standards!
Kuromi has standards!
It's even stocked with fresh supplies.
I think I work...
Look at the fucking Sanrio popularity character contest!
Do you know where Bassmaru is?
In the popularity rankings for Sanrio characters?
It's so low!
Kuromi is a top 5!
She's a top 5 gal!
And she deserves a top 5 man!
Anyway, so we can feed our friends when we find them.
Since you're here, do you mind helping me with something?
What do I have to do?
What do you want me to do?
Dan Black...
These padded holders are missing some umbrellas.
I found one across the street and I have a feeling they're scattered around the resort.
Ideally, I like for each table to have an umbrella.
Would you mind seeing...
Oh yeah, that's easy.
Here I come!
Don't worry, I got you, kiddies.
Hahahaha, this thing...
But Kuromi...
NO!
She does not have a crush on Bassmaru!
I refuse to let her have a crush.
Oh, none of this is working?
Kiddy, how can you run a cafe if none of these work- Oh wait, they work!
Oh I don't have...
Is that a heart?
No, that's a strawberry.
Okay, I was like, what the fuck?
Oh, I can like- Wait, I have to make my own dessert?
That's fucked up.
Keep going.
I refuse.
I refuse to let Kuromi go beneath her standards.
She deserves a top 5 guy for a top 5 Kuromi.
I don't know what creature she is, but she deserves better.
I like how...
Let me put this... Oh, there's a picnic basket!
Can I steal it?
No, I can't.
I can't steal it.
Which place is this?
You know how Kitty has a boyfriend and his name is Dear Daniel?
And she also has a sister?
I forgot her sister's name because no one really cares about her.
But there's this Hello Kitty lie on the internet where if you look up Dear Daniel...
It's like... What was it?
They say Dear Daniel was at... Oh my god, I forgot what the lie was.
I remember I googled it.
Her name is Mimi.
No one cares about Mimi.
No one cares.
She's just Hello Kitty.
Okay, maybe I care a little bit because she has a yellow bow.
Yes, Hello Kitty has a boyfriend!
His name is Dear Daniel.
DDs.
The double Ds.
Uh...
Everyone forgets Mimi.
Thank you.
I forgot Tuxedo Sam existed also.
It's a new vibrant purple cloth.
I can make good use of it.
Oh, I got thread.
Don't worry, I'll never come back to the store, Tuxedo Sam.
I don't need clothes.
Yay!
Alright, this is the last time you'll ever see this guy.
Greetings and salutations!
By pure chance, I stumbled across the perfect location to open a clothing emporium.
Egg Planet... Oh yes!
Hello Kitty also has a cat called Charming Kitty.
Don't think too hard about it.
Like, don't think... She... She...
And apparently, like, the creator was like, she's not a cat.
Like, the creator of Hello Kitty was like, Hello Kitty is not a cat.
To like, justify her owning a cat.
Um, I plan to keep myself very busy until the rest of our party joins us.
Uh, in fact, I already had my first customer!
I had the honor of outfitting Chuckle Cat in explorer wear that was both stylish and functional.
Yeah, it's like a goofy Pluto situation.
I'll be honored to serve as official clear for a merry ban.
Let me guess, do you need something?
Well, normally I wouldn't pose, but I'm facing a rather odd dilemma.
I need assistance in displaying and tailoring my designs.
I'm quite at loss without clothing stands to aid me.
Would you mind searching around for some?
Um, well, guys, if you guys didn't just jump off the plane, you would have all your stuff.
I may see some outside.
Okay, I think... I think, like...
The villagers here are a little stupid.
Like, they literally jumped out of the plane.
And was like, we don't need our luggage.
Alright, we got one clothing stand.
Ooh, let's grab some strawberry crepe.
Wait, what's this?
What is that?
What is this?
Funny how that...
Oh, a comic!
Where did you come from, Batsumaru?
What's that over there?
What?
Where the fuck...
Where did he come from?
Monster Envy, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Part of Hello Kitty's lore is that she is British.
Oh, yeah, yeah, by the way, she's British.
Hello Kitty, ba-da-ba-da-dum.
I used to watch the Hello Kitty show.
And then, like, I had, like... I remember, like, my parents...
Like, when VCRs were a thing, we taped, like, Hello Kitty episodes and stuff.
I would always... Oh, wait, no, not tape.
We... I had, like... Hello Kitty tapes.
Of, like, the one with Hansel and Gretel with Hello Kitty.
And then the Hello Kitty and Friends.
Hello Kitty, ba-da-ba-da-bop.
Hello Kitty.
I mean, you're trying to set a trap for me.
A comic book store would be the bait.
Well, I'm gonna hang around here for now.
Okay.
Alright, so... Wait, am I friends with Batsumaru?
Oh, he has, like... He's a fisherman.
Okay.
Okay, so that means we can fish in this game, too.
Of course, Batsumaru is the fisherman.
Alright, Batsumaru, I have a gift for you.
Give.
Small gift, big spell is open?
I'm totally there!
Whoa, my Melody gave me some water balloons?
I like how... I think I love how, like...
This was, like, Melody's gifts.
But then, all the villagers are like, Oh my god, Doki, thank you so much for giving it to me.
Oh no, one popped all over me.
Is that a crab in the background?
Does this count as a prank from my Melody?
I think it's funny that...
That they're like, Wow, Doki, thank you for the gifts that came from my Melody!
We're better friends now!
Oh my god, a magnet.
Okay, three paper and a magnet.
Okay, what do you want, Batsumaru?
Since the water balloon I got from my Melody burst, I want to try and get another one.
I bet we could make one with some of that rubber around here.
What?
Will you collect... what?
Rubber grows... oh!
Rubber grows on trees.
Usually they grow up on hills, but I also saw one by ChocoCat's tent.
Here, take this.
Then!
Okay.
Okay, we're gonna grab... find some rubber.
Water balloon crafting plans.
Don't we need like a process?
To like, fucking make rubber?
Once you have the rubber, we can make the crafting...
Oh, there it is!
We got a crafting table too!
Prank preparation.
Stolen present.
Valor garlics!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Where's Retsuko?
Where's the model?
I don't want to talk to these people.
When can I kick them off my village?
Just like Animal Crossing.
When can I force them out of the village?
So I can have my optimal village.
Oh my god, what is that?
Is that ye?
I can't catch it yet, cause I don't have a...
I don't have like a bug net.
Okay, let's grab all of this for...
Fucking tuxedo sham.
Where's the...
There's like one more, but where is it?
What?
There's like one more somewhere here.
The fuck?
Where's the last one?
It says it's like around here.
But like, we're around here.
Is it like...
Here somewhere?
Like hiding?
No.
I'm so confused.
Oh well.
Let's see who cares about what he wants.
Anyway...
What's that?
Is that a bug?
Oh, it's right here!
Guys.
Guys, this is not a children's game.
It's actually pretty difficult.
Here you go.
I finished a mission.
This is a very difficult game, guys.
Three cheers for the champion!
You have provided valuable service!
That's me!
I'm currently in your debt.
Yay!
I got another magnet!
Woo!
Okay.
What's this?
Oh, I can trade items for clothes!
No.
We don't need clothes.
What we've learned is that we do not need clothes.
We are perfect.
Guys, look at us.
Oh my god.
That hat is so cute though.
Imagine if I had that hat on.
No, but we don't need it, guys.
We're so beautiful already.
We're wild and free.
Chat.
Wild and free.
Alright.
Oh, he's like the sporty type.
Veggie bread?
Wait, he's a vegetarian?
Is that canon?
Is Pachaco vegetarian canon?
My melody really knows.
He knows what I like.
Okay.
Strawberries.
Alright.
I like how someone's like, no!
My Pachaco lore!
The deepest lore.
No!
The fact that Pachaco's vegetarian.
It's ruined.
Hey, have you seen a little egg throughout the...
No, what?
What little egg?
Look over there.
There's one right now.
Where?
Goop Tama!
There's multiple Goop Tamas?
But what if we took a picture?
Maybe one of our friends will know.
Here, take my camera.
Get to where you wanna take a picture.
Press the camera tool and then you can adjust the camera.
Feel free to strike a pose while you're taking a picture by using your phone.
When you're ready to snap that pic, just press the camera again.
Oh my god!
It's Gautama!
I love Gautama!
I talked about this before, but when I was younger, I bought this little cute Gautama thing.
Where you open the fridge, Gautama would come out of his egg.
So you put the Gautama thing in the egg carton, like in the egg drawer.
And then when you open the fridge, Gautama would come out of his egg and be like, Close the door!
Like in Japanese, and it's so fucking cute.
And it does that every time you open the fridge, so it reminds you to...
It's there to remind you to close the fridge and everything.
It's so fucking cute.
Oh my god, there he is.
Gautama.
Oh my god, wait.
No, not like this.
Okay.
I need to take a selfie with Gautama.
Oh my god, Gautama.
Give me a sec.
I need to take a selfie.
I love you, Gautama.
No!
Oh my god, it's so difficult to lie to myself next to you.
I need to take a picture with my Oshii.
One of my many Oshii's in Sanio.
Gautama, please.
Gautama!
I wanna face the camera!
Okay.
Alright, let's see.
What's this?
Oh my god, I could've just done that.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god.
Yes.
Yay.
Accept.
That's so... No!
He's gone!
No!
It's like, they give me one freebie and then I'm hooked forever.
That's how they get you.
They give you a freebie and it makes you long for him.
He died.
No!
Gautama!
Into the picture you go.
You absorbed him into the picture.
What's this?
Signs seems like a weird egg creature on it.
Maybe...
Oh, it's Gautama!
It's Gautama!
Alright, Gautama.
What do you want?
Oh no, I'm not giving you anything.
What do you want, Pachaco?
Hot potato!
Nice pick!
Let's get everyone over here.
Hey everyone!
Look at this sick-ass picture!
The Doki-tuk!
Guys, you know, it was pretty good though.
It was... See, I stole.
Gautama stole.
What's going on, Pachaco?
Game of the year.
That's what's going on.
Take a look at this picture.
Do you know what this is?
It's Gautama!
They're called Gautama!
Strong, thank you for the magenta soup!
Thank you, thank you!
You fool!
You fell for the classic plunder!
I first came across them in France when I was training to be a professional baker.
Gautama!
Huh?
Crazy!
It's a whole race!
I know, right?
What?
It's funny, they look like lazy things who don't...
Shut your mouth!
Except, I spot them in every corner of the island.
Did you know I take an island jog every...
morning?
I do now.
Look, I want everybody to enjoy the island's rugged challenge and stunning views.
You can't take a vacation while pushing yourself to the max, right?
And Gautama can be anywhere, right?
So I'll cut you a deal.
You can have this camera, but only take pictures with different Gautamas all over the island.
Make sure you strike a rad pose in your picture.
Hehe, I'll give you a hint to start.
I saw Gautama hanging outside my cafe.
Oh my god!
Easy, easy.
No cheating.
Let's start with six Gautamas.
That's a half a cartoon.
Also, it has to be a different one in each picture.
Can you handle that?
I was born ready.
I love him.
I love... I love Gautama.
I like how I was like remembering now of like how Nicewig was like, you never say I love you.
And I'm like, that's not true because I'll say I love you to Gautama.
You can always return for the sign just to check how many you've taken pictures of.
Gautama deserves it.
Oh my god.
I love him so much.
I love you Gautama.
He's so cute.
Gautama.
Okay, I will always have like Sanrio phases.
The great Gautama number 10.
The fuck is that?
What the fuck is the great Gautama?
Okay, let's grab this.
Got a mystic stone.
Oh my god.
There's like fishies.
I can like fish.
Did I drown?
Oh, whoops.
Oops.
Almost drowned.
Alright, quest.
What do I have to do?
The right tools power... What the fuck is all...
Oh my god.
I did not realize there's so many quests here.
Okay.
Power up the gate.
Taco 2.
Okay, we're gonna find Choco Cat.
We're gonna do the main quest.
I don't care about the side quest honestly.
Where's my guide?
Yellow paint time.
Yellow paint, take me to Choco Cat.
Yellow paint.
This is so nice.
Yay!
Oh, what's this?
Oh, that's the crafting table for the rubber.
We have to craft the rubber for Patsumaru.
What did I get?
Oh, I got a blank book.
I can make a story out of this.
I heard you can play multiplayer.
I saw like the multiplayer like panel.
Hello, Choco Cat.
Oh my god.
Are they on the other side of that?
Alright, here's your gift, Choco Cat.
What's this?
An old photograph?
My Melody found while cleaning up the shop?
Incredible!
This might have been taken on the island forever and ever ago.
Where is this location?
Please, open the door.
I need to find Patsumaru.
Open the door!
Yay!
Small gift, big smile.
Okay.
I'm studying this gate to see how we might be able to open it.
I think our missing friends must have landed behind this gate to find them.
You have to...
Oh my god, how do we open it?
How do we open it?
Give me Kuromi.
At least Kuromi.
I was just studying the runes on the door.
Where is Retsuko too?
No one ever said where Retsuko is.
The door will open with a power source.
More specifically, yellow power crystal.
See here?
It looks like the ancient plans for some kind of power crystal sensor.
A power crystal sensor?
If my translation is correct, we'll need three sticks and three magnets...
to create the power...
I have two!
I have two magnets!
I've got what we needed.
I don't actually...
Oh, I do!
Do I actually?
Wait, do I actually have it?
I was lying.
Oh my god, I do!
Let's go!
JK, I was not lying.
Yay!
I got the crystal sensor!
The fabled power crystal sensor!
Typical magnets equals magic.
Guys, science is practically magic, chat.
Use the sensor, type the button, and select it.
The closer we are to a yellow power crystal, the faster...
What is this Chaos Emerald shit?
The faster it will pulse.
Oh my god, it's like those like...
metal detectors.
Okay.
Am I... doing it correctly?
Oh, it's pulsing, right?
When I get closer to one?
How do I know?
ChocoCat, how would I know?
What the fuck?
What the fuck is this?
What... what is that?
What did I spray out?
Hey look, there's a butterfly.
No!
Where are the crystals?
Oh, it's like a little mini game!
Don't worry, I drown.
Guys, don't worry, I drown.
No!
Where is the crystals?
Am I stuck?
Oh, I got stuck!
And it kicked me out!
I can jump, but like...
No, Choco!
Where is the power crystals?
Please...
I just wanna find Kuromi.
It's beeping!
It's near!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
It's nearby!
Where can it be?
Oh!
It's here!
Perhaps if we work together, we'll be able to open it.
You stand over here and I'll stand on the other side.
That's right!
We did it!
Oh my god, is this where... is this mining?
Wait, there's mining?
What the fuck is this?
Oh my... what?
Hahaha!
We're mobile gaming for reals now!
Oh my god, there's fucking dungeons!
In my Hello Kitty game!
This is Minecraft now.
It's Minecraft time!
I got stamina apple slice?
Oh my god, what the fuck am I gonna do with this?
Oh, I'm climbing.
What am I gonna do with this stamina apple slice?
Yay!
Yellow power crystals!
Okay, we got...
Oh!
Wait!
I can glide!
Can I die?
Oh no, there's a...
Hahaha!
I got stuck on the pillar!
The game was like, trying to kick me out of the pillar.
Oh my god, we're mobile gaming for real.
How many power crystals do I need?
Did it tell me?
I don't remember if it told me.
Okay.
Did it tell me how many?
I'm all set.
Okay, there's no...
They...
They accounted for like...
Wait, who the fuck is this guy?
Who's this guy?
Hello?
Is he just gonna stand here?
Is this a statue?
Oh, it's a statue!
I thought it was a real person.
Oh, Choco Cat's dead.
Whoops.
Oh, there...
There he is!
It's like, where did he go?
Choco Cat, where did you go?
Stick.
I'll grab some stick.
What's this?
Sand Dollar.
Oh my god, it's like Animal Crossing Sand Dollars.
Better than World of Warcraft.
100% better than World of Warcraft.
Butters was right.
Oh, that's the sprint.
Okay, we don't need to do that.
We're not gonna play that game.
Look, this is important!
We need to find Kuromi!
Kuromi!
Please start beeping!
Start beeping!
Where is the queen?
Oh my god, where is it?
It's not beeping anymore.
Oh, it's right here!
It's up here!
Yeah, this game is actually real.
I think the funniest part for me about this game is the fact that it's like the same type...
Like, the same name as the Cell Puck reference.
They did that on purpose.
They had to do that on purpose.
Just for the memes.
The other thing is that I can't believe Sanrio JP agreed to it.
Because this is like NA's idea.
You know?
It's obviously like NA's idea to do it.
So I'm more surprised that JP agreed to it.
Because you know...
You know, it's Cell Puck.
The fact that they agreed to have a reference...
Like...
To like Cell Puck...
In the end is actually crazy.
Where the fuck is it?
Weeeeee!
It's so vibrating.
Is it down here?
Oh, it's here!
It's here!
I found it!
It has to be this dungeon.
No, please.
Open up.
Open up!
I need to see...
I need to rescue Kuromi!
Oh no, what the fuck?
There's a puzzle?
No.
Oh no, no!
Okay, we gotta figure this out, guys.
Oh, I know, I know!
I put this here.
Guys.
Guys, these puzzles are very difficult.
Children...
This is why this is not a kids game chat.
This is exactly why.
This is not a kids game.
A normal child would not be able to figure this out.
Unlike me.
Oop!
And then...
Pick that up.
Oop!
Yay!
Another power here!
I got another yellow power crystal!
Let's go!
Thanks ChocoCat for not helping.
Oh no, I need to figure out where the last one is.
Where is the last...
Where is the last power crystal?
Oh, but chest.
Chest time!
A flower.
You know, I was like looking at...
Wait, is this...
Oh!
Should it be this?
It should be this, right?
Was I here?
Oh, it is!
I fucking knew it!
I knew it!
Is it though?
It's not.
How do I...
How do I get up?
Hello?
Oh no, it was just...
It's just a normal chest.
Okay, this doesn't matter.
This doesn't matter.
It's just a normal chest.
Wait, where's ChocoCat?
Where did ChocoCat go?
It left me.
ChocoCat?
Oh, it's this way.
Just a moment.
Where is he?
Take a look at that!
What, the tree?
Oh, it's over here!
The power crystal sensor indicates a yellow power crystal on the island over there.
But this bridge will not sophisticate us across.
My melody is quite handy.
Perhaps she will be able to help.
Why not to get her to help?
She's gonna ask...
What the fuck?
Where did you come from?
She's gonna ask me to get her something.
Like, she's not gonna do it for free.
She's the Tom Nook of...
Of Sanrio...
Hello Kitty Island Adventure.
She doesn't do shit for free.
And I don't think she does it for free either.
A broken bridge?
I may be able to help.
I bought a lot of thrilling materials and I'm gonna get it.
I'm gonna get a dozen of strawberry crates when we came.
I haven't found them all yet.
See?
I told you.
If you can find two strawberry crates...
Oh, I have those already.
Never mind.
I already have it.
Perfect!
Give me those to me and we'll look at that bridge.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God I picked up everything.
Bringing the strawberry crates.
All right.
Yay.
Oh, I have like fucking eight.
Oh, you found the crates!
Nice work!
Let's go to that broken bridge and get it fixed up.
Let's go.
My Melody Avatar palette.
Oh, I don't need that.
I'm already the perfect color.
I'm the dragon colors.
All right.
Come on, Melody!
Go do the work now for me.
So I can...
So I can like be friends with your cooler, hotter roommate slash sister slash cousin.
All right, Melody.
You built that bridge.
Let's see what we can do.
What can we do with this?
Oh my God.
She's so handy.
Wow.
There.
Ta-da!
All fixed.
Wait, what is that?
What's what?
I got three sticks from the extra.
I guess like she...
She like couldn't finish using all these sticks.
How did she do that?
Oh, wow.
It's wonderful.
I'm so happy.
Oh, what?
You don't see the infinite potential in this place.
Wait, is this my new home?
It just needs some tender loving care and I'll become a beautiful house.
We can fix this place up with three more strawberry crates.
Once you have them, use the sign outside of the visitor cabin to start repairs.
Where's the visitor cabin?
This one?
Oh.
Oh, some more friends will show up.
Oh my God.
Yes.
Yes, I have it.
Please.
I have it.
Let's fix this place up.
Please.
So tomorrow...
Please come visit.
Isn't it beautiful?
It feels so much better that we worked on it together.
These homes can be found all over the island.
Decorate and customize them to attract visitors like dear Daniel.
And more.
Oh my God.
The better you decorate it to your taste, the better...
Aw I just need to decorate it to look like, look like Santa Mara's house.
Oh you fucking...
This is how they get you.
I think Melody was like, come to my store and buy the furniture for the ones you want.
Oh my God.
You bitch!
No.
Oh my god, I'm so sad!
This is how they get you.
What do I get from this though?
Weeeeee.
Oh shit, I went the wrong way.
Oh shit, I went the wrong way again.
Guys, I don't think I'm gonna fucking do this challenge correctly.
Weeeeee.
Unless- No!
Oh hey, I got a crate though.
You stopped yourself.
Guys, I was very mad.
I might have got a little toxic.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe this is how she's getting me.
No!
Oh no!
How do I get out of here?
Oh no.
Oh, he's right here.
No!
You can't swim for longer than two seconds!
Okay, here we go.
Oh no.
I'm like trying to remember how to fucking get back.
He's gonna want those wacky digits on the back of the cart if I knew it.
I knew there was a pay to win feature.
You actually have to pay to get your favorite villagers.
It's like the amiibo cart's all over again!
It's like the eBay store for that fucking cat!
And the Animal Crossing!
Yay, I got the power crystal!
That's messed up!
I just run a- No!
Tom Nook is nothing compared to my melody!
I need- I can't.
I need that- I need Sunamoro.
Does she have Sunamoro furniture?
She doesn't even have Sunamoro furniture!
In order to get friends and family to visit our island, we need to decorate the visitor cabins to your taste.
And to order- And in order to decorate cabins, you need furniture.
Luckily, you can buy furniture here.
Of course.
Of course I can.
What should I buy?
Well, different visitors have different tastes.
Why don't you open the visitors app on your phone?
There you see what dear Dan- I don't want dear Daniel.
Why are you pushing dear Daniel onto me?
I didn't call Daniel?
Oh my god.
Find dear Daniel's likes on your phone.
Bro, I don't want him on my island!
Alright.
Where is he?
Why does that- Why?
Why?
Daniel!
I don't want him!
What the fuck do I look at?
Oh, visitors.
Here you go.
Oh my god.
Who the fuck are these guys?
Oh, grandma?
This is your gr- Why would I get your fucking grandma, Melody?
Melody!
Work on your own relations with your grandma?
Why do you have to pay for your grandma's furniture?
I was like, who is this?
Mickey, my Melody's grandpa?
Tam?
There's more of the penguins?
Tam and Pam?
Who's- Oh, okay.
He's Tuxedo's younger brother.
Okay.
Pam is the younger brother.
Your whole family?
Hahaha!
I like- I like it's like her whole entire family!
Why do I need to fucking buy furniture for your entire family?
Melody!
Not even Sam.
I know, right?
What happened to Sam?
Okay, Daniel.
Where is Daniel?
Must be in Seaside Resort to be near- Oh, kitty.
He's like, you gotta be near my girlfriend.
Hahaha!
Okay.
Alright.
Dear Daniel is a charming, sophisticated world traveler and photographer.
Boyfriend to Hello Kitty.
He has a keen eye for- Wait, he's a fucking photographer now?
Must have three pieces- I like how he's just like, I just want furniture.
And must have mama's apple pie.
Oh yeah, cause they're like, they like apple pie.
I remember that.
Okay.
I can't believe she's making me buy furniture for her fucking entire family!
That's so messed up, Melody.
Did you check?
Yes, I did.
It looks like dear Daniel likes mama's apple pie and three pretty pieces of N furniture.
Why don't you get something for him now?
Okay.
I guess I'll get a kawaii alarm clock.
Alright.
Here we go.
Tuxedo Sam's younger recolor.
Karlox, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Kaz, yeah, happy with just three pieces of furniture.
Yeah, he's a guy, alright.
Yeah, as long as he's close to his girlfriend and also like, um, and also just has three pieces of furniture.
Doesn't need to be a bed.
Just like, furniture.
That's all that matters.
Okay, we need a- I'm so sad.
I'm actually so sad.
That- that- that- that Sonamoro isn't in the guest list.
TV, PC, and PS5.
I love that there's like this Reddit where it was like, um, you know when it's a guy's room or like a guy's studio apartment due to like the pictures of like- The pictures of the fucking apartment or studio apartment.
And it's literally like- It's like there's nothing on the walls or it's- There's sometimes nothing on the walls and it's just a bed.
Yeah, is it male's living spaces?
Okay, we gotta- We gotta put the yellow gears on.
Look, if it works, it works exactly.
That's all that matters.
Guys.
I'm so sad that I might have to buy a new iPad.
I can't- I can't open the resort gate.
I was like- I can't- guys, I can't keep using my dad's iPad for this game.
Well, we- now we can explore the inner sanctum of the island.
I'm so happy to have been a part of this.
Thank you so- Huh?
Oh my god, it's a robot!
Look!
The gate is projecting a holographic image!
I saved money from not- like, GamerSubs was like, Don't worry, Doki.
You don't have to pay for the prize pool anymore.
And now I'm spending the prize- I'm spending the money which I would have given for the prize pool for a new iPad.
I was like, yay!
I got to save money!
And I'm like, well, gotta spend that business expense on the iPad for street.
Where am I?
Hello?
Whoa, you're sensing it?
Oh no, it's her situation all over again.
Oh no, ChocoCat's falling in love.
What algorithms were you used in your coding?
Do you use neural networks to process information?
Balargus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I never bought posters for my college dorm until one day my mom got frustrated and brought me more.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, sorry.
I'm ChocoCat.
Nice to meet you.
What's your name?
I'm Top Hat.
Yes, Top Hat.
So, do you live here?
We only just arrived on the island not long ago.
Um, I don't know.
I can't remember anything.
Nothing at all?
That's odd.
Well, except I was floating way up high.
I saw that too.
You're floating over the island.
Yes, but what were you doing up there?
Did you...
Did your plane cake make your mouth function like ours?
What happened to that plane?
Is that plane gonna crash somewhere?
We never went back to the plane situation.
Well, maybe inside the theme park we'll find some things that will help you.
Like more crystals.
Would you like to join us?
I think...
Grrrrr...
I hope he's okay.
Me too, ChocoCat.
Me too.
Well, let's go in.
Maybe we can find a way to help him.
Alright, time to help him.
It's at the bottom of the... What the fuck?
Where did you come from?
Okay, I'm gonna use the bathroom real quick, guys.
But I'm gonna make sure to hide...
I'm just worried about my AFK.
I'll be right back.
I'm gonna use the bathroom real quick, chat.
I'm back!
Sorry, I'm gonna need a massage.
Guys, I'm back.
Alright.
Alright, ChocoCat.
Am I finally gonna find Kuromi?
Alright, the whole park?
I can't wait to see what's out there!
There's so much more to explore!
I hope you'll be able to find the rest of our friends and deliver their welcome gifts.
And I hope that we can find out more about our new holographic friend.
Yay!
Can I... Can I find Kuromi?
I can't... I just wanna find Kuromi!
Oops, I dropped an orange.
Oh my god!
Please!
Where is he?
Decorate the cabin!
No, we are not decorating anything.
Who is this?
What is this?
Oh my god, there's like stamina.
I just noticed the stamina.
Wait!
I see her!
Guys!
We gotta climb!
I see her on my map!
Oh my god!
Oh, the frames!
What did I get?
A strap.
Oh my god, there's a frog too!
Oh, I can't swim guys.
She's on the mini map!
Guys, we're gonna find her guys!
We just gotta figure out how to get across.
How to get across!
Oh my god!
This entire area is like...
I'm not decorating!
I don't care about Daniel!
I just wanna find Kuromi!
They're like, please, please Doki, just decorate!
I like how the game is just like, decorate please!
We just need you to decorate!
I don't care about Daniel!
Just give me Kuromi!
Oh hey, flower!
Oh, swamp mallow!
How the fuck do I get across?
I will find you Kuromi!
Oh wait, there's a chest though!
There's a chest!
Give me a sec, I got distracted.
Yeah!
I got pants!
Guys, you think the game is telling me something?
No...
Guys, it's so funny!
The game gave me pants!
I wonder why?
No pants for this dragon!
This dragon doesn't need pants!
Oh, coconut!
Oh no!
Did I softlock myself accidentally?
There's no way!
Okay, we'll figure out how to get around this!
Dude, don't worry!
Don't worry!
We're gonna figure it out!
We'll figure out how to get around it!
Oh, it's like...
Can I climb up this?
Oh shit!
Okay, we're fine!
We're fine!
There's no way!
There must be a way for me to get across, right?
Oh yes, there is!
Oh thank god!
Oh thank god I didn't fuck up!
Lily pad leap, okay.
Kuromi!
Oh my queen!
Oh my god!
Boo!
Gotcha!
Gotcha, didn't I?
You got me good!
Of course you did!
She's here!
Sorry, but I can't resist giving a good jump scare.
I was born on Halloween, so it's in my blood.
I guess that makes sense.
Of course, you're always right.
My queen.
Pleased to meet you, by the way.
I'm Kuromi.
We might have met on the plane?
That was some jump, by the way.
Oh, me too.
I was so excited to see the spooky swamp for myself that I didn't realize everyone was behind me.
Do you know if my Melody and everyone else...
Yeah, they're okay.
They're fine.
Who cares about them?
It's all about you, girl.
It's all about you.
Wow, okay.
Well, if anyone landed around here, I'll track them down.
No, don't leave!
Don't leave me, Kuromi!
Here, I got you a gift.
It was all me, not my Melody.
I got you...
OMG!
It's the latest book from the Sugar Sweetheart's Forever Se...
Oh my gosh, she's just like me.
My Melody knows I'm their big...
No, no, I knew that you're that biggest fan.
Kuromi.
Please.
Aaka-supa, you Kuromi.
Say my name, please.
Kuromi, don't leave.
I love you.
Kuromi.
I was born on Halloween.
What do you expect?
Do you need something?
I have a question.
I just want to talk to you.
She's just like me.
Any tips about gifts?
What do you like?
Hello Kitty?
No, no, no.
What do you like?
I don't care about the others.
I mean, have you ever seen anyone look better on the beach?
Not the fucking beach.
Where's Pom Pom Perrin?
Okay.
Oh, my God.
I got to meet my queen, my Oshii.
Guys, can I get a kiss?
Guys, I met my Oshii guys.
Wait, wait!
Kuromi!
Meet and greet!
Oh my god!
Kuromi!
No!
Please!
I paid so much for the...
Kuromi, please look at the camera!
I paid so...
Okay, wait.
Okay, maybe like I'll set...
I'll set here!
I'll set here.
It's okay, I'll set here.
So it looks like we're...
It's okay.
I'll just stand here.
But yay!
Wait, what is this?
Yay!
Okay, wait, wait.
No, she has to be normal.
And...
Oh, low battery mode.
That's not good.
Let me...
Wait, wait.
Let me try...
I just didn't...
I have...
I do have a charger.
Don't worry.
I didn't realize I was playing for so long, guys.
I didn't realize.
I got so absorbed.
I got so into it.
I got too into it, guys.
Give me...
I do have a charger, so do not worry.
Guys, do not worry.
I have it right here.
I hear you.
Pull this all the way over here.
All right.
Don't worry, guys.
I need it to be...
No, why aren't you close to me?
No!
Don't worry, guys.
It'll be fine.
I just need...
My cable is a little too short.
Wait for me.
Can you help me?
Oh, my God.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, my God.
Am I charging?
I don't know.
I have the iPad on my lap now.
Okay.
Let's see.
Oh, my God.
Oh, yes.
Yes.
Oh, my God.
Guys, guys, I got a photo of my Oshie.
We got a photo of my Oshie.
Hey guys!
I'm so happy!
I love her.
I love Kuromi.
Oh hey, yeah!
It's me!
You're getting the 12.9 inch iPad Pro.
It's 1.5!
And before tax, wherever you're seeing money, starting the fun!
Darkblade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Yeah, I don't know why it's here, but it clashes with the spooky vibes it's got going.
Is that a button on the mailbox?
What does that mean?
Delivery service.
Let's see.
Activate the mailbox.
Whoa!
Is this fast travel?
Kuromi, why are you... what's glowing?
I never did that before.
Then again, I never... yeah, I never bought it to touch it.
I wonder why it's glowing.
Anyways, you came just in time.
I was hoping to send over this pumpkin to...
My melon?
But I'm right here!
Kuromi, she'll never appreciate you like I do!
Kuromi!
I'll deliver the pumpkin!
You don't do any work.
Your hands are not meant for work.
Cherry seed pumpkin.
Thanks!
That's a big help!
It's okay, Kuromi.
Don't do any work, Kuromi.
I'll do it for you.
My queen.
No!
They were girlfriends.
I refuse!
Kuromi!
Okay.
An old mailbox.
Someone must know how to use it.
I do.
Wait.
How do I deliver this?
Deliver that pumpkin?
Do you need something?
I have a question.
What's up?
Would you break up with Melody?
Kuromi, please.
She doesn't deserve it!
Guys.
How do I convince...
The dachoki just got received.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
How do I convince her?
That she's...
I need her to like...
Break up with Melody.
She does not...
She does... Melody does not deserve her.
She deserves someone better.
Like a certain bird person.
You need to let...
No!
I'd rather her be single!
She doesn't deserve it!
No!
None of them matches my standards!
None of them match my standards for Kuromi!
I can't believe it!
Alright.
Let's see.
What do I need?
I need... Oh, delivery service.
Give my... I have to walk...
Discover Sinamoro speedy delivery...
Sinamoro!
Where are you?
Wait!
Sinamoro?
Wait.
How the fuck do I use it though?
What the fuck?
Wait.
The Sinamoro speedy service...
How do I use it?
Excuse me?
Someone must know.
Who's that someone?
Who...
Sorry, Kuromi.
Oh, hey.
There's an apple.
Oh, I can't get there.
Sorry, Kuromi.
Sinamoro's... Sinamoro's my first.
Sorry.
The moment I find Sinamoro, I don't need you anymore.
I just...
I need to find him.
He's my first.
He's my first Sanrio love.
Kuromi.
Hey.
I can't believe we jumped out of the airplane.
I'm Kuromi, in case you forget.
Nice to meet you, Kuromi.
You know if everyone is okay?
I didn't see anyone else land with me.
Um, they landed in the resort.
Whew.
Okay.
That's good to hear.
Black, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't wait to tell Bat-Smarto about that jump.
And hopefully, get some friends to help fix this place up.
Where the fuck is... Oh, hey.
Here's a gift.
I'm just gonna chuck it at him.
I don't care.
Well, a guide to island critters?
Isn't my Melody great?
Yeah, she's so great.
Here, since you came all this way to deliver that gift, let me help you out.
There are plans to craft flippers which let you swim.
Oh, wait.
I actually really need that.
I've been like, drowning myself.
Here's what materials you'll need.
Where's like the crafter?
Guys, I need to find Tsunomoro.
Guys, I need to find Tsunomoro so I can take a picture.
Kuromi, my child.
Where is it?
Where's Tsunomoro?
Tsunomoro.
Where are you?
Maybe Tsunomoro will appear when I go back to my Melody.
Oh my god, I got it.
He'll show up when I... He'll show up when I see my Melody.
I believe.
How the fuck do I get out of here?
Phew.
Alright.
Okay, there's the gate.
My Melody... Oh, wait.
I need to craft the flippers.
I really need the flippers, man.
Oh, I can just craft it.
Nice.
Oh yeah, she's also great.
Gouki growled.
Growl.
Yeah.
She's so great.
First...
I have mail for you.
My Melody.
Melody, I have some mail.
Please.
Please look at this mail for me.
Oh, okay.
Let me...
Oh, it's because I never...
Did I never activate this?
No, I did.
So, I need to...
I'll just give it to her here.
Here's your fucking mail.
Tsunomoro.
Oh my god, he's so cute.
He's helping.
Look at the...
Oh my god.
Tsunomoro, no.
No.
Okay.
Look at me.
Look.
Yes.
Look at me.
Oh my god, he's looking at me.
Okay.
Wait.
I need my camera.
No, I don't want to shop!
I can't take...
Oh.
Okay.
It's your time.
No.
Okay.
Alright.
And then...
Oh my god.
Wait.
No, no, no, no, no.
Not this one.
Wait.
Cancel.
I can't stop.
I can't stop waving.
Please.
I'm so embarrassed.
Tsunomoro, no.
Look at me.
I'm so embarrassed.
No.
Look at me.
Yes.
Look at me as if you admire me, Tsunomoro.
Okay.
And then I'm gonna look at the camera.
Oh my god.
He's looking at me, guys.
Guys, he's looking at me.
I'm like his biggest fan.
And then...
Oh!
Okay.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Actually...
Oh my gosh.
Which one?
Maybe like...
Dancing?
No.
Not dancing.
Maybe...
Yes.
Accept.
Oh my god!
Ah!
Look.
Oh my god.
I'm your biggest fan.
I don't care about anybody else, Tsunomoro.
You're so cute.
Look at his cute outfit.
Sometimes when there's a cute outfit, I'm like, oh my god.
I give him a 15.
One-minute, don't look.
Are you looking for me?
Yes!
Yes, I have a question.
How can I help?
Any tips about yes?
What do you like?
I don't care about her!
I don't care about Melody!
Dear Daniel, bro, I don't care about Daniel either!
Can I get a vibe check?
You haven't discovered enough of the island to determine your island vibe score just yet.
Oh my god!
What?
There's a vibe check?
I guess you can get your present.
I don't fucking guess.
So...
A what check?
A vibe check?
Give me one second, I'll be right with you.
Just sign here.
Oh my god, he's like the Amazon delivery guy in this game.
Here you go!
Thanks, Cinemoro!
Oh, do you know Cinemoro?
Yes, I do!
I'm your best friend!
I'm your biggest fan!
I'm your number one donator on your YouTube channel!
Lollipop, a nice picture of Cinemoro and a dragon.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey there!
Please!
I'm your number one donator!
Thanks again for delivering the pumpkin.
I've been a 10 year membership!
I have a 10 year membership to your channel Cinemoro!
I'm in your fan club!
It's hard to get spooky things at the Seat Side Resort.
Can you do me a favor and deliver this coastal aquatic plant to Kuromi in the...
Okay.
It's something that would be hard to get out of the spooky swamp.
Guess I gotta bring this back.
I'll tell her I got her that plant.
I don't want to impose, but I can...
Oh!
Yes!
Yes please!
Follow me!
Of course I'll follow you everywhere!
Let's go!
Let's follow...
Let's follow our first...
Our first gen real love.
Hello Cinemoro.
What do you want to tell me?
Hey, when did...
I've seen one of these in the spooky swamps.
That's fantastic!
You've already come across a fast...
Oh it is fast travel!
I knew it!
Throughout your journey, you've already come across a fast...
You will come across these mailboxes.
Upon activating the fast travel mailbox...
You'll have the ability to be delivered back to this spot...
at Cinemoro speeds.
Oh cool!
No more walking back for me!
Now please activate this mailbox.
Did I not activate it?
Yeah!
You know that mailbox was found...
You found in the spooky swamp?
Since you already activated it, you can return there at any time.
Just select your map and select the icon...
Then select a destination.
In this case, please choose the spooky swamps.
No!
Where did he go?
I was going to take a picture with you!
Oh my god!
Oh I can take a picture with all of them!
Okay.
Okay I gotta take a picture of all of them.
With all my Oshis.
All of you guys.
Look back.
Oh my god!
Yes!
Okay.
Okay and then I wanna...
I'm gonna do...
And then get the fuck away from there bug!
And then I'm gonna be like...
Yeah!
Which one?
Oh my god!
Me and my Oshis!
Me and my Oshis guys!
I paid a lot of money for this meet and greet!
With my Kamiyoshi!
A fucking course at Cinemoro!
Cinemoro and then Kuromi is my second!
You're my second!
Oshi don't worry!
Mmm...
I'm not creepy!
I swear!
She's my second one.
And then Kutama is the third.
Kutama it's like...
And then it's like...
Cinemoro, Kuromi, Kutama...
And...
and...
Pompompurin.
No problem in here.
I'm not gonna mention Melody.
Oh it's so cute!
Friendship ended with Kuromi.
Now, Cinemara is my best friend.
Doki probably.
Hidden thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I mean, whatever.
Oh my god, she's just like me.
Guys, I know like... okay, look.
Look, I love... I love Kuromi, but like...
You never forget your first and Cinemara was my first.
You... you never forget your first.
So how do you like the...
That was amazing, Cinemara!
Oh, it's my pleasure.
When you're out there on your adventures, just make sure to keep an eye out for any more mobs.
Of course.
Do you wanna live here?
Do you wanna...
Do you wanna live... Friendship!
Oh my god, Cinemara, I got you some gifts.
What do you like?
You like bonus.
You like those puffs.
And then you like...
Coffee, chocolate, and salt.
Okay, guys.
Maybe he'll like live here now.
Where is it?
Who the fuck are they?
Oh my god, oh my god.
There's like his girlfriend and then there's...
Oh, there's Baku!
There's Baku and then there's...
Alright.
We should like not... we should... we should not get his girlfriend on the island.
We should...
Which one was it?
This is his girlfriend, Moka.
Um... the leader of the...
Moka is like an older sibling to the group.
Sometimes bossy, but often sweet.
She also likes to show off the flowers in her...
We're not getting his... his girlfriend's not gonna be in...
Uh... in this...
On this island.
Wait, that's the sister?
Who the fuck is the girlfriend?
That's the sister?
I thought that was the girlfriend!
Oh shit.
Guys, this is how little I care about his girlfriend.
I...
Was it Chiffon?
It has to be Chiffon, right?
Cause this is like cappuccino.
That's cappuccino.
Or was it espresso?
Is either espresso or...
No, he does!
He has a girlfriend!
This is... this is like...
There's literally...
You cannot say that...
You cannot say this is a kids game.
When fucking dear Daniel is in this game.
And they've been like pushing Daniel at me so hard.
Like...
Literally says...
Boyfriend to Hello Kitty.
No, he does!
He does have a girlfriend!
It's true!
Is it Chiffon or...
Espresso?
This is how little I care about his girlfriend.
Oh, Chiffon.
Fucker.
You don't deserve him.
You don't deserve him!
He's the peppiest member of the Cinema Angels.
She is an avid sports fan.
And is always eager for a lively game.
You don't deserve him.
He had a girlfriend.
You're right, guys.
We're never letting his family live on our island, guys.
Never.
Who's this guy?
Part of...
Is this guy new?
I've never seen this guy before.
R301, welcome to the tournament!
Holy shit.
They made it up for me when I'm parasocial.
Look.
Look, I'm not gonna say...
I'm not gonna say that, but like they deserve so much better.
They deserve more than what they can give them.
I know somebody that can give them what they want.
Oh my god.
Are you gonna live here now, Tsunamaru?
Are you gonna live in my village?
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
Tsunamaru is gonna live in my town.
Oh my god.
What are my other missions?
I've not cared about my other quest ever since I found Tsunamaru.
Friendship.
Okay, Kuromi, what do you want?
Kuromi.
Kuromi, what do you want?
I'll be level 4 friends with you.
Kuromi.
Do you want pumpkin?
Here.
Here's a pumpkin.
Oh, you are?
Here you go.
Oh, a light stone.
Okay, that's not pumpkin, but... Level 2!
Oh my god.
I have the Kuromi Avatar Palette.
Wait.
What does Tsunamaru want?
Tsunamaru!
So I can be my Oshis colors.
Tsunamaru is gone!
No!
You left away!
It's okay.
I can be number 2 Oshi colors.
How do I change my colors?
They never taught me how to...
No!
My Oshi!
Do you want a pumpkin?
I have a pumpkin.
Here you go.
You ran away.
It's over.
Do you want another gift?
I have another one.
Here, take all my pumpkins.
And take all of it.
Friendship grows!
I'm level 3!
I'm level 3 now.
Do you want another gift?
Oh... wait.
Can I give 3 gifts a day?
No!
I can't love bump.
Kuromi!
Kuromi, please!
I know you set a limit on Super Chats.
Kuromi, I used up my Super Chat limit.
Kuromi!
I'm gonna make a new account so I can give you more Super Chats.
It's so good over.
Kuromi, please take my... please... please take my pumpkin.
Please, I show you my pumpkin.
Please.
Kuromi, please.
I'll make a new account.
Kuromi, please take my pumpkin.
No!
Kuromi!
Please.
I'm such... I love Kuromi!
Darklight, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Kuromi, no!
Don't turn me off!
I'm here to give you my support.
I don't understand.
Was that ghost?
Why is there a fucking ghost?
Who are you?
Choose a hat?
It's like... new hat.
I meet the eye... Oh my god.
They're all like hat ghosts or something.
Who the fuck are these people?
Okay.
Okay, the order is like...
It's...
It's Sinamoro, Kuromi, Kotama, Pampa, Peren, and then Retsuko.
Retsuko is the...
Retsuko is the other one.
It's on the...
Where are the hats?
I don't wanna fucking exchange hats.
Oh yeah, I can swim now too.
Where's Retsuko?
We gotta find Retsuko.
Where is she?
The ghost tour gallop?
Oh, I don't care about that enough.
We gotta find Retsuko.
Retsuko.
Kuromi is about to follow his training.
Waiter.
Ivy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm so tired.
It's Sinamoro.
Yeah!
Yeah, he was!
I took a photo with him earlier.
Go brain.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I took a photo!
I took a photo with him!
With my Oshi.
With my Kami Oshi.
Guys, I'm lost.
Where am I?
I'm actually lost.
What the fuck?
Oh, that's just a rock.
I was like, what happened?
I got fucking eaten by the rock.
Guys, I'm so out of place that the map stopped loading on my top left corner.
The map is just gone on the top left corner, guys.
That's how lost I am.
There's no more maps anymore.
Where am I?
I'm in the gemstone mountain?
How do I get out of here?
The map is just white.
There's like no areas anymore.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, there we go.
Okay, we're safe.
We're safe now.
Okay, the dune lagoon.
Okay, we were here.
We were here.
This is where we found...
This was a spooky forest.
Oh, there's fast travel.
Fast travel.
Yeah!
Where am I?
I'm having a ghost tour ride now.
Okay.
We need to find...
We need to find Pom Pom Purin.
He's like somewhere here.
We found the spooky swamps.
But...
We can't find...
Where's Pom Pom Purin?
Pom Pom Purin!
Okay.
There's a castle over here.
Maybe Pom Pom Purin is over there.
imiz
Good morning!
Darling!
Good morning.
Well,
it's a little dark so we're not going to sleep here.
It's a little red.
We're going to sleep here, right?
We're in a house.
We're in an apartment.
He's not... he doesn't even show up in the maps!
He's just gone!
I just wanna farm pom-pom pudding!
Oh wait, I got stuck.
I missed the Kutama.
No!
And I missed the Kutama!
Oh my god, I'm a mess.
I'm a fucking mess right now.
Oh, you can't just cheese the maze.
You actually have to do the maze.
I thought I could climb it.
He's off the grid!
He should be here!
He landed on this side!
Oh my god, hat!
There's a hat on one of them.
Wait, I'm gonna steal his hat.
Wait, is this like a game?
It is, right?
One game ticket for one- grab as many ghost apples.
You're gonna blow my nose, Ginse.
Oh my god!
How many game tickets do I have?
I can do this.
That can't be difficult.
Plus two apples.
Grab.
Grab, grab.
Do I have to come back to him?
Grab.
Don't worry.
Look at the speedrun.
Look at this fucking speedrun.
Wait, there's a power crystal here?
Wait, there's a power crystal here.
Oh, chest.
Oh, I can't open the chest.
I have to keep grabbing apples.
Oh no.
Wait, 16?
Don't worry, I'm not lost.
I'm just gonna spam.
Grab.
Is that chopsticks?
What is that?
The fuck is that?
Oh, it's Gautama!
Yes.
Oh my god, it's Gautama.
Oh, I can't take a photo.
No!
I Gautama- I tried to take a Gautama break and the game was like, Doki, please.
There is another game you have to play.
I was like, but Gautama.
Gautama- No!
The Gautama fucking- Great job.
Here is a prize.
I still got a prize though.
I got blue brain hat.
Oh, I got a hat.
And I got five apples.
Wait, I wanna wear this hat.
How do I wear this hat?
Hat time.
How do I wear it?
Is this?
Where?
What's it look like?
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
Okay.
It's a little freaky.
We'll make it work.
We can make this work.
Mojo Jojo?
Jagun Gun Gun.
Guys, we can make it work, guys.
Can I like look at this?
Where's Pom Pom Pudding?
Oh, there's another world here?
Wait.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Wait, there is another world here.
Where is he?
Oh my god!
Where'd you go?
I like how Pom Pom Pudding is like, where is he?
He's over there.
There?
How do I get there?
Wait, what?
He has his own store that's like 200 miles away.
Holy shit.
Guys, the main plaza is like here, guys.
Why are you all so far away?
They're lost in the fog.
Okay, now that I know where he is, I'm gonna go back to the resort plaza.
Okay.
We're gonna meet Ritsuko first.
It's bigger than the Tears of Kingdom map.
I still don't know how to change my appearance.
I wanna be my Oshis colors.
But like, I don't know how to change my colors.
Okay.
I have a nice hat now.
This is a cute hat, not gonna lie.
This is me as an introvert.
Let's pick this up.
I'm gonna pick this up though, real fast.
Yeah!
Alright, we're gonna swim to Ritsuko.
Ritsuko, don't worry.
Oshi number five, I'm coming over.
Don't worry, Ritsuko.
You might have heard about me from the others.
Wait, am I going the right way?
There's an island here for food?
What is that?
Do you guys see that island on the map?
Don't worry.
I'm gonna swim over.
I'm gonna swim over to you, Ritsuko.
Ritsuko!
Oh, that's cute.
An exposed brain.
I know, right?
Don't worry, Ritsuko.
Saving private Ritsuko.
But there's a store right here, I think.
On my map, it shows like some fucking store.
Oh, wait.
Nice.
Fast travel.
We actually need that.
Yay!
Anything for my Oshis.
Ritsuko!
I need a boat!
Whoa, what's this?
Oh, nothing.
I was just...
Sorry.
Sorry, I got a little distracted.
Ritsuko!
I'm coming!
I'll do it.
I'll travel around the world for a boat with my Oshis!
I love you, Ritsuko!
Oh, hey, there's a house here too.
Oh, wait.
There's a...
Do you have a hat?
We can swap hats?
Oh, you don't have no hats to exchange.
God.
Damn it.
He has no hats for me.
I got a die patch?
Where did I get that?
Like, what?
Okay.
Where...
Where is she?
Oh, she's over there.
Ritsuko!
I'm gonna climb up this wall!
It looks like I can't climb up this wall just to see her.
Let's go!
Climb up this...
Oh, I got soft locked into that wall.
How do I get to you?
Oh, I'm so scared.
Ritsuko!
I don't understand!
It won't let me climb this mountain!
To, like, convince them of my love!
I'm gonna climb.
Oh, I figured it out.
I figured it out.
Oh, my God.
Here I come.
Ritsuko, I'm coming over.
Don't worry.
I'm coming.
Oh, my God.
My other Oshii!
This is how dedicated I am to the cause.
Oh God.
Okay.
Ritsuko!
Oh, wait.
What's this flower?
Oh, my God.
Maybe she'll like that.
Maybe...
Hello?
Ritsuko?
Is someone there?
Yeah, I'm over here in the bushes.
Would you be able to help me?
Oh, my God.
Of course I can, so you'll owe me forever, Ritsuko!
Remember my name!
I'm Doki Bird!
Hello!
Thanks for helping me out there!
Oh my gosh!
Of course!
I jumped out of Tsunamaru's plane!
This was Tsunamaru's plane?
Oh my...
Tsunamaru, I love you man, but don't ever drive a plane again.
Now you owe me forever, Retsuko!
And this debt can never be repaid.
I landed in the bushes and got stuck.
Oh, where are my manners?
I'm Retsuko!
Oh my god, nice to meet you!
Oh no!
My luggage!
No!
Don't cry, baby!
I must have floated off course as well!
I'm gonna stay here and look for my belongings.
If only I had friends... I'll be your friend!
One mini-credits ticket for Pom Pom Pudding, please!
Thank you for the super chat, Zecra!
Thank you!
Oh my god!
Retsuko!
Okay, okay, alright.
You, you...
Yeah?
Nice.
Okay, I'm gonna move you.
Alright, here you go.
We're gonna take a picture, okay?
You and me.
Yes, you look like that.
And then I want Retsuko... I want you to...
I want you to make...
Make this expression for me, alright, Retsuko?
I want you to make this expression.
And then I... I will make...
I will make this expression.
Hahaha.
Or like... No, no, no.
No, actually, no.
What do I do?
No, oh, wait, no!
That should be your expression, yes!
And then I'd be like...
I'd be like... Wait, I need like a good word.
Yes!
I'll be like, you owe your life to me now, Retsuko!
Hahaha.
Retsuko, my friend.
You're on vacation, Retsuko.
Can I help you?
I'll let you relax.
Girl.
So here's a gift that I found just for you.
Bro, Melody didn't give her a gift!
Melody never made her a gift!
That's so fu- Don't worry.
I'll be your friend!
Who cares about her?
Oh my god!
She didn't give her anything!
Don't worry, here's another Cinnabloom.
I got you, girl.
I got you.
You're so kind.
I'll be your only friend, Retsuko.
Be your only friend.
You don't need the other people on the island.
You just need me.
Nice, I received another dough.
Yeah!
I'm like, I'm like...
Level 2!
I got the Retsuko Avatar Palette.
Nice.
Okay, now we gotta...
Now we gotta find Pom Pom Puddin.
Alright, where's Pom Pom Puddin?
Pom Pom Puddin is like right here.
Don't worry.
Travel across the world.
Your parents still...
That's a joke.
Look!
Look, Melody never made her a gift!
That's so fucked up!
Just because Retsuko is newer is the newest...
Okay, she's not even a new addition too.
She's not even a new addition!
And Melody never even made her a fucking gift in the first place!
Can't believe it!
She deserves better and I'm the better one.
I'm the better.
Okay, I got Red Power Crystal.
What the fuck?
Oh, there's the fast travel.
Let's grab that fast travel real fast.
Alright, nice.
We're almost there to Pom Pom Puddin.
I think?
Where is he?
Yeah, he's like to our right.
Look!
She made a gift for Pom Pom Puddin!
Oh no.
Thank God.
I love how whenever the game knows I'm stuck, like it helps me out.
Pom Pom Puddin!
Don't worry!
I'll save you!
I'll be a hero!
No!
Let me...
Okay.
Okay, we gotta...
How do we get there?
Okay.
Wait, how do we...
How do we get to that side?
No.
No!
This island won't fucking forbid me from seeing my other Oshis.
I will meet all my Oshis!
What the fuck is this?
What is this?
What's this side?
What the fuck?
Mysterious...
Oh!
Alright, I guess I'll never be able to read that.
Oh my God.
Mountains are fucking denying me of meeting my other Oshi.
That's so fucked up.
Let's grab...
Wait, 20...
What?
I'm literally charging it.
What do you mean?
Oh, it's because like...
Okay, don't worry guys.
Although I know it says like 20...
Wait, I can climb this.
I'll fucking brute force this.
I'll brute force this.
Come on, let me climb this.
No.
No, it's too far.
It's too far away.
No!
Please, let me meet my other Oshi before I lose all the batteries!
I don't know how!
I'm stuck.
No!
I'm trying to figure out how to get to him!
I'm literally walking around the mountain.
Oh!
Yes!
Okay.
I'm on a time limit now, guys.
Whoop.
Is it gonna kick me up?
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Alright, we figure out how to get up.
Oh no, I'm stuck again.
Oh my God.
I unlocked the map.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
We don't end until the end.
Until we meet our other Oshi!
Okay, wait, wait.
I'm gonna recharge stamina.
I figured it out.
Recharge the stamina right here.
Okay.
We're gonna do this.
That's right.
Yes!
The things I do for the people I love.
This is it.
Oh my God, I see him on the map, guys.
Let me meet him.
This has to be him.
This has to be where you live!
Oh my God.
I'm floating down.
Pump, pump, put in!
I'm floating down!
Don't keep doing the sequence breaks.
Oh!
He runs an ice cream store!
We've been looking for you.
I had plenty of time for a nap.
I'm pump, pump, put in, by the way.
You never go in front of me and my Oshis.
I'll always find a way.
I think I saw you in my dreams during my...
No!
Maybe this is a sign I should go back to sleep.
This non-functional ice cream boat is a great nap spot.
But I do wish I had a clothe...
Let's become friends!
Let's become friends then!
Friendship and naps, the best thing...
Oh my god!
I'm Pum Pum Puddin's friend!
I'm in!
I'm actually in!
Here you go.
I'm in!
Of course Melody knew I'd need a tasty snack after the plane.
She's so thoughtful, isn't she?
She's so me.
Oh my god.
You mean I'm so thoughtful.
Oh my god, he gave me a banana.
Friendship rose!
I'm now friends with Pum Pum Puddin!
Alright, we gotta take a picture.
We gotta take a picture.
Look at the...
Look at the camera!
Yes!
And then I'm gonna be like...
Yay!
Or maybe like...
Ah!
Not a stalker.
Not a stalker by the way.
We did it.
We found all our Oshis guys!
We fucking did it!
Yay!
I wonder like who else can we have for visitors.
We suggest...
Oh there's like Pum Pum Puddin's mom and dad.
And like sister?
Wait, Pum...
Makaron is a golden retriever who styles herself to look like a poodle.
She wears an...
Oh my gosh, I didn't know about Makaron.
I didn't know about Makaron.
Okay, that's so sad.
But Retsuko has like no visitors.
Like that's...
That's like...
I don't know.
It's a little fucking sad.
Like...
Like everybody has like a visitor except for...
Except for like Retsuko.
Is that like the girlfriend?
Must be in Gemstone Mountain to be near Pum Pum Puddin.
Is this the same?
Wait, is that the girlfriend?
Does Pum Pum Puddin have a girlfriend?
He had a girlfriend.
Not anymore.
I'll be your only neighbor.
Pum Pum Puddin.
Don't worry.
Look, I'm your colors.
I'm your Oshii colors.
No one told me there'd be so much walking for this trip.
Can I talk to you?
What's up?
Any tips about this?
Okay, I don't care about Kadopi.
I only care about you.
I only care about you, Pum Pum Puddin.
Alright, guys.
Guys.
I think this was a good place to call it.
Oh my god.
The...
I hate...
I met all my Oshis.
I think this is a good place to call it here.
I met all my Oshis today.
And I think I'm gonna...
I wanna leave it on a high note of leaving all the Oshis.
The iPad agrees.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
How to be parasocial.
You don't understand.
I do it for them.
You like that meme?
Do it for her?
Do it for them.
Do it.
I got my meet and greet, guys.
Yay!
I met everybody.
Meet and greet accomplished.
Yay!
You don't understand.
They are my Oshis.
I got a photo.
And I got...
I got my meet and greet.
And they accepted my gifts too.
I had a great time though.
This game seems fun.
I wish it wasn't region locked.
I'm so surprised.
That it's region locked.
I thought this was like...
I thought it would be like outside...
Like people outside of NA can play it.
Maybe EU?
Can EU people download Hello Kitty Island Adventures?
Cause like I know like for Asia you can't.
Apparently.
Cause my dad's Asia account couldn't download Hello Kitty Island Adventures.
That's so weird.
But it was so good.
I can't talk about it.
I don't mean all my Oshis.
Oh my god.
There's multiplayer.
I didn't bring up the multiplayer cause I was worried.
I was scared.
Additional parental permission.
You can change this.
Online features enabled.
Oh!
Invite code.
I can send an invite code or something.
Wait what is my invite code?
Apparently there's like multiplayer.
I'm like looking through it.
There's multiplayer and everything.
How do I change my colors?
I'm looking through this right now.
You guys can't see it but like I'm looking through it myself just in case.
Hahaha.
Uh.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Cute stream.
Oh my god I got a dress.
Oh my god.
Guys there's daily rewards and everything.
How do I change my colors though?
It doesn't tell me how to change the colors.
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
Can they give me stuff if I...
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
Wait.
JL...
Okay we actually don't.
I'm not gonna say what the last one is.
Alright never mind.
I don't know how to detox me if I have somebody join my fucking room.
Never mind.
I didn't see the last two.
Hahaha.
I got worried.
I was like wait.
What would it look like if somebody tries to join my room?
Hahaha.
I almost.
Guys sorry I got too excited.
I got way too excited.
I was like oh my god.
We can like.
You can like give me free stuff.
In my world.
Hahaha.
Oh.
That's fun.
I'm glad I got to finally.
Fully experience.
Hello Kitty Island Adventure.
Finally for reals now.
I'm so happy.
I've always wanted to play this game.
And uh.
You dumb me.
It's okay I didn't.
I didn't say out.
There was like two more letters that I didn't say out.
So thank god.
You guys.
Hahaha.
I closed the game too.
I closed the game.
Just to be sure.
I didn't accidentally.
Fuck up.
I closed the game as well.
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
I met Kuromi.
I met Tsunamaru.
I met PomPomPurin.
I met Tetsuko and Kutama.
I don't care about the other ones I met.
I can't believe all my favorite characters.
Were like locked behind quests.
That was so fucked up.
Of course like the ones I don't care.
Or the ones I have to communicate with first.
Hahaha.
I met all my Oshis.
Yay.
Anyway guys.
I had a great time.
I hope you guys had a great time watching.
Even though it was just me fangirling.
About my Sanrio Oshis.
Hahaha.
But I had a great time.
Hanging out with you guys.
I'm sorry the stream was an hour delayed.
Hahaha.
With all the stuff going on.
I'm so sorry.
The stream was an hour delayed.
But now.
Now I know.
So I hope you guys still had a great time watching.
Even though it was an hour late.
But I always enjoy streaming for you guys.
Everybody.
Yeah no.
Fuck Apple though.
Oh my gosh.
Apple is so fucking convoluted.
For no reason.
Like it was so difficult just to log in.
Like I couldn't believe it.
Anyway guys.
As always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
To get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me.
Head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye.